essentially results motivate me
so one there are great results it's a
great excitement a great maturation when
you get something you you try to learn
more about these new things it's like a
chess game it's always it's always a
game and it's always nice so when it
becomes a routine then it's hard to
motivate yourself and at that moment you
have to move to another area and others
are there and this is what I was doing
for the last 20 years when the scenes
becomes boring and not exciting try to
find anywhere research one you can
stimulate yourself with new exciting
things I often think of little mouse at
one end of the labyrinth and at the
other end there is a prize at the cheese
piece of cheese and mouse cans smell but
how to get there and it's very similar
we should we should you know pursue a
goal with utmost rationalism and utmost
optimism rationalism and optimism those
are the two things that a professor
Brown uses and I have used I don't need
motivation it's my it's my hobby as well
and i extremely enjoy what I'm doing if
I'm not enjoying it any of the
particular experiments on just dropping
it off so I just it's just self
sustained process if you enjoy it you
you do it if you don't enjoy it you just